the Blue Wave abs to a purple puddle as
Democrats take control of the House
Republicans increase their majority in
the Senate and Republicans edged out
Democrats on key governorships we will
analyze why House Republicans lost maybe
president Trump's game then baito gets
beat oh and uses his concession speech
to audition for a spot on pod save
America most important of all President
Trump gives a broadway-caliber press
conference and the show goes on as
Attorney General Jeff Sessions resigns
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
you know I was pretty nervous last night
we were on camera doing election
coverage for about six hours or
something we're I felt like we're on
forever and I thought you know there's
gonna be nothing in the news tomorrow
we've covered everything right now but
leave it to President show business
president Kofi Fei to give us some
incredible news just breaking now
Attorney General Jeff Sessions embattled
for many months now in a feud with
President Trump has officially resigned
at the request of Donald Trump we will
get into all of that in just a second
but first let me tell you about honey
you know honey I've been using honey for
years long before the Daily wire existed
honey is the best way to save money on
the Internet because you don't have to
do anything
you just you install it in your browser
so it takes two clicks you install it
right in your browser and it is a free
shopping tool that automatically
searches the internet for the best promo
codes every time you buy something
online so you were just always getting
the best deal you log in to Amazon or
wherever you want to shop and that says
okay the price is ten dollars and then
you look at honey and it says hey dummy
do you want to save four dollars you say
uh yeah I'm not I'm not a dummy I'd love
to save four dollars and you just do it
and you just save money automatically
honey has already saved listeners of
this podcast an average of 46 dollars
and 89 cents don't be one of the losers
who doesn't save money get in there and
use it it's great it works on Amazon
eBay Etsy j.crew Best Buy Newegg
Skillshare Walmart all over the place
many many more so I couldn't tell you
the last thing that I used honey to buy
because I use honey to buy everything I
use honey to buy virtually everything
online and have for years do it has 10
million members hundred thousand
five-star reviews it's the money saving
shopping tool that everyone can agree on
get it for free get honey for free join
honey calm / co' f fa ce o-- v f EF e
that's right type it in join honey calm
/ cough fa co v fe fe honey the easiest
way to save money while shopping on lime
I'm a little bit hungover today I'm not
because we drank so much but we were
just talking for hours and hours with
all that smoke with all that
we weren't eating very much and all of
that Co FFA there were there was
initially a flood of leftist tears that
affected the Senate then we were call it
right-wing tears because it would
actually the Democrats won a relatively
modest number of seats it wasn't the
blue wave even Democrats are admitting
it wasn't a blue wave but still they got
back control of the house so that there
is all of these emotions all over the
place and the the real question is how
should conservatives feel about all of
this it wasn't we didn't get to guzzle
those leftist tears I'd be much more
hungover if we guys old those leftist
years last night but how do we feel I
think one the turnout was insane last
night we the turnout was record high I
was hearing it from people all day long
and the numbers seem to back it up she
had a record high turnout I mean tens of
millions of more voters than were
expected from previous midterm elections
that is a big win for Republicans that
is two Republican candidates and the
president Trump who in many ways
nationalized the election in the off
year when your party is in the White
House your turnout is generally
relatively low because you're happy
things are going fine it's the other
side which is motivated to turn out so
we expected very high Democrat turnout
and we saw Tea Party levels of
enthusiasm among Democrats we also saw
very high enthusiasm among Republicans
that's a big win for Republicans that we
could motivate the Republican base in
and off your election that was a big win
the Democrats took the house they didn't
take it by a lot a blue wave would have
been if they took it by 50 seats even
maybe 45 seats or 55 or 60 or 63 Barack
Obama lost 63 seats in his first midterm
election Bill Clinton lost 54 seats in
his first midterm election the Democrats
it looks like they picked up anywhere
from 28 28 is what I think been
officially cold right now but it looks
like they picked up about 34 seats
somewhere around there okay how
disheartened should we be about the
Democrats taking the house I don't
really care I don't really I would have
loved it if Republicans had held the
house because it would have shown it
would have bucked the historical trend
so much
it would have been such a mandate for
this administration to govern that it
would have been irresistible we would
have loved it but practically speaking
because the Democrats took the house who
cares who cares what were Republicans
doing with the house anyway
what were they real I mean we got tax
reform that's good what else anything
else did we get we didn't get
entitlement reform we didn't really get
a spending decrease we did what did we
really get out of it what were they
doing you know in part Jeremy boring the
god-king was talking about this last
night in part this is because for the
last 10 years we've been running against
earmarks pork-barrel spending the kind
of spending where one congressman says
all right I'll vote for the spending in
your district if you vote for a bill
that has spending in my district and
then we both get to bring home the bacon
for our constituents and we'll get
reelected and this was the way that
politics worked in this country for a
long time and it incentivized
legislators to vote on legislation so
jeremy boring now is saying we bring
back the bacon bring back the earmarks
and he makes a very good case for it
which is that if you don't have pork
barrel spending nobody has any incentive
to vote on anything so you're just all
you can do is grandstand and then go
back and obstruct and then go raise
money in your district and you're not
actually legislating that's what we've
seen you know the Republicans won the
House of Representatives in 2010 this is
this amazing tea party election took
back the house what did we get for it
because then Republicans took back the
Senate in 2014 as a matter of
legislative accomplishments what did we
get we were told when we took back the
house that we had to take back the
Senate to get anything when we took back
the Senate we were told we had to win
the White House to get anything when we
took the White House what did we get we
got tax reform that was great we almost
got Obamacare repeal except John McCain
voted it down John McCain ruined our
chances of that may he rest in peace
and so what did what did we really get
that we were promised as early as 2010
that we're gonna reform entitlements the
biggest driver of our debt and deficit
the young guns Paul Ryan's gonna do it
did we get that no we did not for lack
of trying on Paul Ryan's heart but we
didn't so now that we've
the house what's the legislative loss
they won't make the tax cuts permanent
but nothing is permanent in politics and
we won't get entitlement reform which we
weren't gonna get anyway okay we kept
the Senate we actually gained seats in
the Senate what does that mean
it means that the judges are gonna keep
rolling in president Trump has done a
great job and cocaine Mitch has done a
great job of getting judges appointed to
federal judges and obviously on the
Supreme Court
it means we'll get more of that that is
probably going to be the legacy of this
first term you know if and if that is
the legacy that's pretty good if the
legacy is executive orders deregulation
out of the White House and all of these
federal judges that's a win great I'll
take it
the big question by losing the house
that is now gonna be asked is can
President Trump still win if he loses
that sounds like a contradiction in
terms but he's just lost something he
lost the house historically it seems
inevitable that he lost the house in
many ways they lost it by less than they
should have locate blah blah blah
whatever they lost the house president
Trump's charm so much miss charm is that
he wins he wins wins wins all the time
he never loses and that's held true this
guy has been talking about running for
president since the 80s but he never did
he didn't quite do it until he knew he
could win until he saw his opening he
took it and he won he beat out a
extraordinarily qualified Republican
field knocked him down one by one 16 17
candidates then he took down the House
of Clinton so he's got all this win win
win now that he has lost a little
something can he maintain that charm and
he maintain that air of invincibility
the Teflon Don I suspect he can I
suspect he can because of how he handled
himself in this press conference and
frankly I think that losing the house
will give great political benefit to
Donald Trump holding the house would
have given great political benefit in
the sense that it would have been such a
mandate to govern but now President
Trump has an adversary and we'll get to
why that matters in a second so what's
the good news
GOP extends that Senate majority and the
GOP picked up key governorships so this
means look the the map in 28
was pretty good for Republicans in the
Senate it's not gonna be so good for
Republicans in 2020 the Republicans are
gonna have a lot more seats that they
have to defend unlike this time when
Democrats had a lot of seats that they
have to defend but now that we're
looking at a gain of three maybe four
seats in the Senate it's gonna be a lot
harder for Democrats to take back the
Senate in 2020 which means that if House
Democrats want to impeach President
Trump like they've been yammering on
about for the last three months they can
impeach him that's fine but there is
statistically a 0% chance that they
convict him and remove him from office
we also picked up some key governorships
some really big ones in in states that
we were told we're gonna flip and we're
gonna go for Democrats the reason that
this matters is one because of
redistricting it means the Republicans
will have at least a seat at the table
in redistricting when that comes up and
make sure that Democrats don't
gerrymander things you know out of
control gerrymander themselves into a
House Majority and and but the big pick
up was in Florida so just just some of
the major upsets some of the key GOP
wins here Mike Braun beats Joe Donnelly
in Indiana polling told us Donnelly was
going to win
what happened major upset Mike Braun
beats Democrat Joe Donnelly in Missouri
Democrat Claire McCaskill lost to
Republican Josh holy another what I
always suspected that Holly was gonna
beat McCaskill and I actually thought
that Braun was gonna be Donnelly too but
really nice to see that confirmed and
then we get to Florida the big win of
the night the guzzling of leftist tears
we'll talk about that in one second but
first let's have a little gratitude
let's talk about operation American
gratitude a wonderful sponsor and a
great organization it was started when
the founder heard that a Vietnam veteran
said on his podcast that he had never
been welcomed to him in 50 years since
returning to Vietnam the goal is to
deliver thank you cards to two million
Vietnam veterans over the next five
years and play so you are not forgotten
card on every Vietnam War Memorial in
America and you can involve your kids in
these projects and you teach them about
patriotism sacrifice and gratitude
that's some all three are sorely lacking
in America right now wonderful wait
teach your kids so that they don't turn
into some crazy blue haired shrieking
anti-american nutcase go to so you can
go to racing Americans dot-com / go FFA
CoV f e f e you'll get all of those
thank-you cards the interview cards p o
wmia cards 58 to 20 card to honor those
who may be ultimate sacrifice 100% of
the profit from Operation Gratitude
gratitude goes toward building the
freedom never sleeps business trading
Center in beautiful Eagle Idaho
that's an on-site six month paid
entrepreneurship training program for
veterans and underprivileged youth make
life better for Vietnam veterans and
also little fellows who want better
lives little kids who can be taught
gratitude and thank the veterans who
defend their freedom all for less than
20 bucks
moreover operation american gratitude
will be your offering a 25% discount
this week only in honor of Veterans Day
coming up as always participating in
Operation American gratitude makes you
fifty percent more likely to meet George
Washington in heaven that's guaranteed
raising Americans calm / co' FFA co v fe
fe get your operation american gratitude
kid today raising americans calm / co
FFA co v fe fe happy Veterans Day
and god bless america so the big big
upset was in Florida Rhonda Santos
Republican Ron de Santos beats Democrat
socialist crony crook Andrew Gilliam
Democrats were already talking about
Gilliam as a possible 2020 presidential
candidate and a real crook in a cynical
awful politician who baselessly smeared
his Republican opponent as a racist
played the race card constantly just an
awful fella
and he got beat ha ha ha ha ha ha
delicious also in Florida another big
win looks like a big win the race has
been cold for Republican Rick Scott the
former governor of Florida it looks as
though Republican Ritz got beat Democrat
Bill Nelson Nelson is calling for a
recount
why because Democrats cannot concede
races ever they just can't do it
Al Gore can't do it Hillary Clinton
can't do it Bill Nelson can't do it they
just whine and moan and complain and
they're gonna keep digging and recount
in those ballots until they find enough
dead and
legal voters to force them into office
because they're sore losers and they
don't treat politics with any dignity
whatsoever
now just north of Florida in Georgia you
had the race between Republican Brian
Kemp and Democrat Stacey Abrams Stacey
Abrams on another awful candidate
empty-headed candidate who said that her
coalition was gonna be made up in part
of illegal aliens that her voting
coalition was gonna be people who she
should not vote for whom it is a crime
to vote and you had Oprah go down there
and campaign on behalf of Stacey Abrams
said we're know that was the final a
couple weeks push you've got to get
Stacey Abrams through what happens Brian
Kemp wins Brian Kemp beats Stacey Abrams
and guess what happens Stacey Abrams
won't concede why because Democrats are
sore losers so they're gonna dig up some
more dead in the illegal votes Stacey
Abrams already promised that she already
said my coalition includes illegal
voters so maybe they'll try to find some
more illegal voters to push Stacey
Abrams through what she's really hoping
for is a runoff so because it was so
close and because there are other
candidates on the ballot she's gonna
hope for a runoff election we'll see if
it gets to that there's been no because
we don't have a final vote count we
cannot call that yet and if there is I
hope Ryan Kent beats her again we go
right through and I hope that ballot
security measures are in place because
you've got a whole Democrat Party and
especially Stacey Abrams openly talking
about illegal aliens voting so those are
I think the most important races why do
those races matter there were other
great wins in Ohio for Republicans
unfortunately Wisconsin governor fell to
Democrats Scott Walker I think has just
been in there too long he's fought very
hard he's been a very good governor
excellent governor in Wisconsin but
eventually people get sick E and they
throw you out and that's what happened
to Scott Walker and the big win in
Florida why do these matter because
these are very important states for the
presidential election you know Florida
for in from Florida is constantly having
votes decided by about 200 votes or
fifty votes it's even between great
candidates like Ron DeSantis and just
awful terrible people
like Andrew Gill
it's still a you know a question of a
thousand votes or five thousand votes
for two hundred votes I mean this has
just been the case since since the 2000
presidential election at least so to win
those swing states looking forward to
2020 that's really important one because
it shows us the the direction of how
people are voting and and because you
know by nationalizing President Trump
made it about him so it's not just about
the Republican and Democrat parties
which is important we want to see how
people break down there but he made it
about him so that we see what happens
when he is on the ballot next time I
think those were all great signs then I
mean those are the most important races
my favorite race you know my favorite it
wasn't in Florida it wasn't in Ohio or
Indiana it was in the great state of
Texas
where senator Ted Cruz beat out mr. bata
mail himself beta Beto Francis robert
Francis Bobby Frank O'Rourke he beat him
out and I'll let bado speak for himself
in his concession speech he turned the
left-wing white guy up to like twelve he
turned it it was already at about nine
and a half and he just turned it all the
way up to twelve by whining profanities
Beto take it away in every single part
of Texas all of you show in the country
how you do this so how do you guys so so
effing proud so you guys you guys
seriously you guys I'm a I'm a serious
person I'm a really serious person in a
statesman I'm such an effing statesman
such a Fe he's just doing that thing
that the pod save America guys do
he's just the grown-up pod save America
guy an admittedly fairly attractive very
effeminate man who uses vulgarity and
profanity to substitute in for coherent
points that he's incapable of making he
is pod save America with about 15 years
on he's probably auditioning for a spot
on pod save America now because he's
unemployed although he really swindled
national
Democrats how many millions of dollars
did this guy raise even as of a month
ago he'd raised 40 million I think total
was something like 70 million dollars
and he barely spent any of it and he
wasn't giving it to other candidates
either so he's probably looking forward
to running for president in 2020 and in
the meantime maybe he'll go on pod save
America and wine and use profanity and
not make any any decent arguments
they're calling this a moral victory the
Democrats you knew they were gonna do
this because Beto
is not just he's not just the pod save
America guys in the future he's also
what John Assaf was a few years ago you
remember John Assaf he was that Democrat
who was running in I was it in Georgia
and they poured money into his race they
said we're gonna flip this seat we're
gonna John us off he looked like bait oh
he was just like a skinny whiny
effeminate white male and they said we
is the one who's gonna win and then he
loses and they say well you know
sometimes losing is really winning no
it's not it's losing it's always losing
losing is losing the winners go and
legislate and the losers go home to
quote cocaine Mitch McConnell that's
exactly what happened here that said
this doesn't bode well for Texas he only
lost by three or four points I think in
Texas this guy is a whiny left-wing just
awful unspeakably repulsive candidate to
me but he's apparently very attractive
to Democrats and they're a lot more
Democrats in Texas every single day this
is happening because California is
emptying out and because our borders not
secure so people are flooding in there
who statistically are much more likely
to vote for Democrats
now let's temper our fears a little bit
here Ted Cruz is a flawed candidate I
like Ted Cruz a lot I've done TV
commercials for Ted Cruz I voted for Ted
Cruz he's a flawed candidate he's flawed
because he got really bruised in the
presidential primary with Donald Trump
he then didn't support the Republican
nominee at the convention which really
turned off a lot of people he then did
support the Republican
so it turned off all the people who were
happy that he didn't support him at the
convention he is just in a tough spot
and he's an extraordinarily intelligent
guys maybe the most intelligent person
in the US Senate
but he's not as good at that pavement
retail politics as Beto or orcas so Beto
had an advantage there and a big-money
advantage Beto obviously had a lot of
money from national Democrats coming in
so okay that's fine if this were let's
say though that Cruz only bit instead of
beating him by three or four points
let's say he beat him by 10 points
that's the in Texas that's still pretty
scary and I don't I think perhaps they
should stop building the wall on the
southern border you just build a wall
completely around the state of Texas so
if it stops getting infiltrated by
Democrats cuz that that is a little bit
of a worrying trend but look guys to
quote the economist John Maynard Keynes
in the long run we're all dead
so we can always worry about things
tomorrow this is I think a lot of when
Ben and I disagree on politics it's it's
mostly attitudinal which is hey we won
we're here today come on that's pretty
good and Ben will say yeah but in 50
years the Sun is gonna explode and we'll
all dies oh cow right yeah I guess
that's true but today is a good day the
other thing I want to point out with
bado
is they they made this such a national
point for Democrats it is imagine if he
went by his actual name
imagine if bado O'Rourke didn't pretend
to be a Mexican he's not Mexican he's
not even one 1000 24th Mexican he's a
white guy his name is Bob his name is
robert Francis O'Rourke and I know we've
been joking about bado and Beto and beta
and robert francis you know imagine if
he actually had to go by his name robert
O'Rourke Ted Cruz versus Robert O'Rourke
would any Democrat care about him
even though I know he's like a little
cutie pie and he wore dresses in his
prog rock band in these 90s or whatever
but I know I get that but would they
actually care about him no it wouldn't
it shows that racial obsession of
Democrats that a 100 percent whitest guy
on the face of the earth can just
pretend to be a Mexican and he will get
national Democrats
support that is pretty bizarre he'll get
tens of millions of dollars from
out-of-state Democrats that is pretty
bizarre and when we pointed it out that
he's a fake Mexican that he's lying
about his race by using that name and
they didn't seem to care they didn't
care one because I think Democrats are
shallow thinkers when it comes to this
these races and they're shallow when it
comes to race it doesn't mean it's just
the appearance of the thing if you're a
man who then wears a dress and says
you're a woman they say you're a woman
if you're a white guy who slaps on the
name bado now you use next time he's
gonna go by like Juan Lopez Juan Lopez
O'Rourke you slap on a Mexican name then
you're a Mexican and this this actually
does have a philosophical grounding to
it it actually comes from the flaws of
feminism leftism intersectionality
intersectional ISM there actually are
philosophical just a rotten core to this
we're gonna get to that a little bit
later when we talk about the Girl Scouts
suing the Boy Scouts but that is the
rotten philosophical foundation of the
modern left that this guy I mean he's
actually a good example because he used
to wear dresses equity was a young man
playing in prog rock bands but talk
about shallowness so I think for in the
future whenever I run for for Senate
from the state of Texas I want it to be
on the record right now I am gonna go as
Miguel Juan Lopez Francisco Knowles so
get that oh and you I want you to start
calling me that
because then when I run I'll say all my
friends have been calling me that for
years what a cynical jerk
he lost hahaha mmm delicious now we have
to talk about Jeff Sessions Jeff's this
is breaking news Jeff Sessions has
resigned they didn't wait very long on
that one we've been wondering if he was
gonna resign for months and months
president Trump has been really hard on
him ever since AJ Jeff Sessions recused
himself from the Russia investigation he
said it's improper for me to be the
point person on the rush investigation
because I was on the campaign you know
and so there's
special counsel appointed he reports to
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
and Donald Trump has been hammering Jeff
Sessions for this I had always hoped
that it was just a show I had always
hoped that they were just putting on a
show oh yeah
Trump hates Jeff Sessions and they're
gonna fight it out but they really liked
each other because Jeff Sessions is a
great guy he's done a very good job in
at other aspects as Attorney General at
the DOJ and he was one of trumps
earliest supporters I think he was at
the earliest major supporter for Donald
Trump and it just seems that actually it
was a pretty bad relationship Trump was
pretty mean to the guy he in his
resignation letter he said that he was
resigning at the request of the
president so he's out now they're gonna
fill that Democrats are gonna crow about
how President Trump is obstructing
justice with the Muller investigation it
remains to be seen what happens with
regard to Muller this doesn't directly
affect that at all
however Jeff Sessions is out I should
point out he's done a very good job in
many other ways he's gotten very tough
on drugs amidst this awful opioid crisis
one of the worst epidemics in American
history and he's gotten really tough on
drugs reversed a lot of stupid Obama era
policies he's gotten a left lot tougher
on illegal immigration he's actually
enforcing laws now laws that have not
been enforced since the 1990s he's
getting back there and enforcing the law
that's really important you know he's
just tightened up the ship he's made
what was a very lawless DOJ under Barack
Obama a corrupt a crooked lawless DOJ
he's made it much more law-and-order
centric and actually his refusal as
frustrating as it is for Republicans and
conservatives does show that change cuz
Loretta Lynch wouldn't have recused
herself from nothing they the the Obama
DOJ Eric Holder Loretta Lynch was so
corrupt so so targeted President Obama's
political opponents and Jeff Sessions
came in and he said we're not gonna do
that we are gonna hold her selves to a
higher standard I give him credit for I
think he did a really good job in many
areas
and I'm sorry to see him go and
hopefully you know President Trump has
replaced bad appointees with good
appointees and good appointees with
better appointees and I hope that that
is the case here but we'll just have to
see what happens
moving forward what we do know is that
the show must go on and that's what this
is all about I think that's why the
sessions resignation came today I think
that's why Trump had this wild press
conference today the show must go on and
it is going on but there is the best
news that comes out of these midterm
elections the absolute best news and the
reason why losing the house is actually
probably a benefit to Trump might hurt
the Republicans broadly but it's
probably a benefit to Trump is that
Trump now gets an adversary he's got
someone to fight against when Donald
Trump doesn't have an adversary he's
fine he treads water he's okay but when
he's got an adversary that's when he
shines when he's got a Jeb Bush to go
after or a crook and Hillary were now in
Nancy Pelosi that is when he shines and
he you know president Trump learns a lot
from Reagan and from Obama
don't forget Barack Obama lost 63 seats
in the House in the 2010 midterms and he
got re-elected in 2012 the Democrats
aren't talking about that very much
right now
so what does it mean it means that
Democrats are going to investigate
everything they're gonna investigate
security clearances conflicts of
interest the Trump Organization porn
stars all that stuff they're saying now
that they're going after tax returns
they're going to get Trump's tax returns
they're gonna see it they are falling
into a trap I'm glad they're falling
into this trap they've probably set the
trap for themselves a year or so ago now
that the Democrats have the house they
can request Trump's tax returns from the
Treasury Department and they almost
certainly will get them but they can't
release them so the fact they can have
their they can't have their tax returns
and eat them too they can have their tax
returns but they can't or they can
pressure Trump to release his own tax
returns but they can't get the tax
returns and then release them that would
be a violation of the law so I just
think they don't learn anything you know
this election should have been a blue
wave it really should have historically
speaking and it wasn't it wasn't even
close to a blue wave they took the house
but no wave at all
and they're focusing on things that
people don't care about they don't care
about the tax returns
no American cares about Trump's tax
returns nobody is gonna win an election
on Donald Trump's tax returns it ain't
gonna happen but President Trump is
playing along he has the trollin chief
and he's got great words for for Nancy
Pelosi plus we will get to this
unbelievable press conference today an
epic smackdown of Jim Acosta but first
I've got a second bite of Facebook and
YouTube if you're on Facebook and
YouTube I'm amazed you're still there go
to daily wire.com if you are already on
Daily wire thank you you help us keep
the lights on if you're not it's ten
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
flavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you have to ask questions that mailbag
you get all that stuff by the way if you
happen to be in Los Angeles tonight and
you're thirsty for some sweet sweet
leftist Cheers and salty come out to
Loyola Marymount University it's 7:00
p.m. I will be joined by the Supreme
Lord of the multiverse himself Andrew
Clavin to entertain and enlighten both
friends and snow-flakes hope to see you
there at Loyola Marymount University
7:00 p.m. Pacific time it's gonna be a
lot of fun you'll need the leftist years
tumblr you're going to need it because
the Trump agenda with the exception of
tax reform has been all through the
Senate not through the house we've made
gains in the Senate we're gonna get more
judges through we're gonna have more
Brett Cavanaugh's I hope you like beer I
like beer I still like beer and I still
like leftist tears go get your tumblr
we'll be right back with a lot
[Music]
so we elected a showman we're getting a
show president from tweet set this out
today he says quote in all fairness
Nancy Pelosi deserves to be chosen
Speaker of the House by the Democrats if
they give her a hard time perhaps we'll
add some Republican votes she has earned
this great honor is saying Democrats are
threatening not to make Pelosi their
speaker because she's a hundred and
fifty-five years old and she's not a
terribly competent person though she's
she is a shrewd politician in many ways
and we'll get to them so the president
Trump is saying that's fine if you're
Democrats won't make you speaker maybe
we'll send you some Republican votes so
that you can become Speaker you deserve
at Nancy and of course he wants Nancy
Pelosi she's one of the most detested
people in the entire country she's a
perfect adversary for him and he'll win
every time that he goes up against her
so we hope we're supporting Nancy for
Speaker Pelosi for speaker 2018 let's do
it
I hope I hope we all unify here at the
Daily wire so he he sends that out we
she's also a shrewd politician by the
way because she's already saying
impeachment is probably not going to be
pursued of course not I mean it would be
so stupid the both Pelosi and Trump
learned the lesson of the Clinton
impeachment which is that when an
overzealous house over reaches you get
political gains for the incumbent
president that's exactly what would
happen no hope of conviction in the
Senate no hope now or in 2020 probably
so it would be a huge waste of time a
huge distraction and Trump could
continue to get his agenda through
executive orders and through the judges
so she's taking that off the table she
also said that they're not going to try
to impeach Kavanagh I think they've
learned from the Cavanaugh effect which
is that the senators who voted against
Brett Kavanaugh basically all got routed
last night okay that's fine that's the
Pelosi side him now President Trump gets
up there and he puts on a show he starts
with the incredibly satisfying smackdown
of Jim Acosta there are hundreds of
miles away though there are hundreds and
hundreds of miles away that that's not
an evasion honestly I think you should
let me run the country
run CNN and if you did it well your
ratings let me ask you a question miss
president for me if I may ask you are
you worried that's enough that's enough
that's enough pardon me ma'am miss me
that's enough miss president I'd watch
out what CNN should be ashamed of itself
having you working for them you are a
rude terrible person you shouldn't be
working for CNN go ahead I think that's
a very rude person the way you treat
Sarah Huckabee is horrible and the way
you treat other people are horrible you
shouldn't treat people that way go ahead
go ahead Peter go in Jim's defense I've
traveled with him and watch them he's a
diligent big fan of yours either so she
showed me the lie she show me the lie
fact-check true on all of that by the
way that was after Jim Acosta asked
about a hundred thousand questions he
wouldn't shut up and he kept what they
weren't questions he's just arguing with
Trump he says that the caravan isn't
invading the country the illegal alien
caravan isn't invading the country they
are they're not American citizens
they're foreign nationals and they're
forcing themselves into the country by
definition that's an invasion
so Trump says basically that and Jim
says no they're not invading they're
just they're just coming into the
country illegally it says yeah okay we
have a difference of opinion but they're
invading and he goes on and on he keeps
badgering and you know there are other
reporters there presumably who want to
ask questions and so finally says all
right that's enough from you and he
smacks him down and he's right Jim
Acosta does treat people wrong what you
didn't see in that clip is that a White
House aide this this young woman goes up
to get the microphone from Acosta cuz he
keeps demagogy and won't let anyone ask
another question and Acosta shoves her
he shoves her away pulls the microphone
back and he shoves her away and and yet
we're told that President Trump is this
is this awful bully and he's a
misogynist oh look at Jim Acosta shoving
a woman who's trying to do her job away
from him and refusing to give up the
microphone and let anybody else speak it
is awful and I love that President Trump
probably alone among possible Republican
presidents right now is able to call
that out it was absolutely right
he also but I'm actually by the way
trying to draft Jim Acosta to be the
2020
mcwrap nominee i think that way that's
the showdown we're all waiting for
that's the is else if you're watching if
you're watching the heads of the
Democrat Party Maxine Waters Hillary
Clinton Michael avenatti I want you all
to nominate Jim Acosta
he owed president from during this great
press conference also fired back at some
of his critics within the GOP here he is
you you suggested he was retiring you
said that many of the retirements that
happened in the house made it very dim
in return that made it very difficult
for you in this election cycle and that
it was because they were Chairman's that
were chairmanships that were vacated but
Jeff Flake wasn't a chairman of a
committee and Paul Ryan also retired the
cycle so why do you think that is whose
fault is it that there was Jeff's cases
me pure and simple
I retired him I'm very proud of it I did
the country a great service go ahead
give him give him he is retired I'd like
to call it another word but we're going
to treat him with great respect go ahead
thank you mister we're gonna treat it
with a great respect that flake what a
beaut what a beaut he is absolutely
right - and a worthwhile point on this
is that the GOP got blown out in the
suburbs in the House races here
they got they got really damaged in the
suburbs which only makes sense this the
rural areas generally vote for
Republicans urban areas generally vote
for Democrats and the suburbs or where
they battle it out but for years and
years now the suburbs have been moving
bluer and bluer and in a in a swing year
in a year that should favor Democrats
it's no surprise that the Democrats took
the suburbs that's the easiest place for
them to take but you know Jeff Flake is
the kind of Republican who talks to the
suburbs guess what even Republicans who
talk to the suburbs lose if you stand in
the middle of the road you're gonna get
hit by a truck and there are there are
few words that I have for Jeff Flake
that I haven't already said on this show
so he can leave it there but he's just
awful he's just the worst kind of
preening narcissist and I'm very happy
that he's no longer in the Senate and we
all should be and Trump did do a
national service in doing that it's also
nice because it shows a certain in
depend
from Trump which is that he's not simply
a partisan guy it mean he hasn't been a
partisan for much of his life he's been
a Democrat he's been a Republican he's
been a Reform Party guy and this helps
him in many ways because it's
frustrating when he's fighting with Paul
Ryan it's frustrating when he's fighting
with members of his own party but I
think it gives him a lot of credibility
for American voters who are not hardcore
Republicans or hardcore Democrats it
shows an independent streak it's
frustrating for those of us who are more
partisan but I you know I think actually
in the long run it probably helps then
he also showed us in this press
conference that the media are not
getting any fairer to the GOP this was
an amazing exchange for with a woman I
believe from PBS talking to Donald Trump
it's not even a question it's just an
accusation here she is on the campaign
trail you called yourself a nationalist
some people saw that as embolden white
nationalist now people are such a racist
there are some people that say that now
the Republican Party is seen as
supporting white nationalists what do
you make of that I don't believe I just
well I don't know why do I have my
highest phone numbers ever with African
Americans what do I have among the
highest poll numbers with African
Americans I mean why do I have my
highest poll numbers that's such a
racist question honestly I mean I know
you have it written down and you're
gonna tell me let me tell you it's a
racist question and mr. president you
know what the word is I love our country
I do you call you have nationalists you
have globalists I also loved the world
and I don't mind helping the world but
we have to straighten out our country
first we have a lot of problems and it's
excuse me but to say that what you said
is so insulting to me it's a very
terrible thing that you said I'm so
pleased that he said this to her and
then he took it the way that it is
because one it's a very racist question
what he said is I'm an American
nationalists and for the American nation
the American nation is not an ethnos
state it's not there is no race called
the Americans
there are many races who have come to
America it was founded by people who
were English and people who were Dutch
and people who were black who were
brought over as
laves and people who later were Irish
and then some Italians when this
Sicilian sardine boat came over and met
up with the Mayflower boat and produced
a little old mate and other people too
other and obviously every race Under the
Sun has come to America
over time to say that you are an
American nationalist is is to make a
statement that that is absent of race
and she says if you're if you support
America you are a racist that's what
she's saying that's why her comment is
racist is she's saying America is a
white country saying America is a white
country but anywhere or in English
country or an Irish country or whatever
and then she says that you said you're a
nationalist and some people have said
that means white nationalists some
people you're some people you're the
some people have said it it admitted at
least have some courage and say I am
criticizing you for this and I'm equated
American nationalism with white
nationalism this doesn't make any sense
when Trump says he's a nationalist he's
spoken with stunning clarity on this he
is saying that he supports the
Westphalian system the system of nation
states that we've had for about 400
years in in this world to preserve the
world order and that independent nations
are the best units of global of the
global order to preserve Liberty for its
people that's what he's saying he
juxtaposes it with globalism which
refers to transnational supranational
empires like the European Union or the
United Nations or any any other okay so
he says this and she says well what
about oh isn't that just like white
nationalism white nationalism is
actually the opposite of nationalism
because there is no white nation there's
never been a nation of the whites in
fact actually the only sound argument
against nationalism is Europe is the
white continent because there are there
isn't just one white nation which is
called Europe there are many of little
nations the French nation the Italian
nation the English nation the Spanish
nation and all of those nations would
fight with one another the argument
against nationalism is that all all of
those independent nations having too
much sovereignty will get all of the
various white people to kill each other
in Europe there is no nation of the
it's that there are there can be white
empires plenty of people have tried to
create empires such as that but it is
not nationalism so it's both a
misunderstanding
what she's talking about but it's also
an awful calamy it's an awful slander
and so he says your question is racist
which is true and then he said your
accusation against me is so horribly
insulting and I'm glad he said that
because they get away with this they've
gotten away with this for decades they
call you a racist and we're supposed to
take it we're just supposed to take I've
had people in ostensibly polite
conversations call me a racist flat-out
or imply that I'm racist or bigoted or I
don't like people of other races and
that's so you know I got two words for
those people though I try to be polite
in conversation so I don't say them very
much but it's awful and the people who
do it should be ashamed of themselves
they behave like children like little
angry hysterical mean-spirited children
and that's how she was behaving and she
and she should sit down and I'm glad the
president Trump called her out for it
the press conference only got better
from there of course because it's not
just that reporters are unfair when it
comes to racial insinuations it's that
they're unfair on questions of basic
history they're actually trying to
rewrite history to make Barack Obama
look better and to make Trump look worse
look at this stunning exchange which for
some reason the left is spreading all
around Twitter right now President Obama
allowed a very large part of Ukraine to
be taken and right now you have
submarines of that particular parcel
that we're talking about yeah it was
that was President Putin who knew annex
Crimea so that was President Obama's
regime that was during President Obama
right I was not doing me it was resident
no that was resident annexation oh it
was President Obama that allowed it to
happen
had nothing to do with me okay that's
exactly right I suppose technically both
of the people in here oh right except
the reporter is wrong because he's
trying to pretend that his point
contradicts Trump's point it doesn't
Trump said Barack Obama allowed Crimea
to be annexed by Russia that is true
Russia was err Crimea was annexed by
Vladimir Putin and Russia in 2014
Barack Obama let that happen brock
obama's supposed to be the leader of the
world he spoke
to go in there and kick the bad guys and
draw red lines and he let it happen
George Bush by the way routed routed
Vladimir Putin out of most of Georgia
when Vladimir Putin invaded Georgia and
Barack Obama failed to do that in Crimea
so Oh Trump makes that point and then
the reporter says well no Vladimir Putin
annexed Crimea like yeah right dummy
that's not the point I'm making I say
the point I'm making is that Barack
Obama allowed them to do it and they're
they're sending this around on Twitter
now prominent blue checkmark dummies you
know probably the pod save America
people I'm not I don't know for sure but
if I had to bet I would bet that those
those kinds of guys are tweeting it
around to Trump is right and they're
trying to rewrite that because they
don't want to admit Barack Obama's
weakness and failure as president but he
failed and I like that Trump is doubling
down on it too
they're trying to rewrite history not
just not just read your mind impugn your
motives they're trying to rewrite
history and we shouldn't let them do it
they also have no idea how the
government works but we're gonna have to
save that for tomorrow because we're at
a time right now you should check out
the speech tonight it's gonna be a lot
of fun I suppose will be more of a
conversation than a speech with me and
the Supreme Leader of the multiverse
Andrew Clavin so check that out I hope
we're gonna livestream it hopefully will
record it too but if you're in town
check it out at Loyola Marymount
University 7:00 p.m. Pacific and
otherwise I'll see you tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show see them
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018